bienvenue à votre premier jour de stage
de formation en zoologie au zoo sauvage
de l'edel rex m'envoie vérifier la larme
de la clinique et il faut que je
m'inquiète ou pas voilà les deux dames
milliards et elle va faire une arrêt
cardiaque
son coeur ne pas plus
ici sécurité est ce que quelqu'un est là
on arrive ce sont les animaux qui ont
besoin d'être protégés par lomé pal
inverse votre boss a dit pas d'armes
où sont les singes et participe tout de
suite je vais me rendre à la boule si un
seul de ces animaux contaminés par le
virus et s'échappe
elle affecte le cerveau des animaux ils
veulent se débarrasser de nous envoyer
tous vous réfugiez tout de suite en lieu
sûr et ce jusqu'à ton talent
on va devoir pousser
tous nous sortir ni science
monsieur koala